>>Allyson: We've seen
success with these students.
Ninety-eight percent of our students
go on to a four year college.
>>Joseph: High Tech High School
is a traditional academic program
with a vocational component.
>>Allyson: The vision of the school
is that interest drives learning.
The academics support the
career and technical vocation
so that you have this really
well rounded, interested,
high level student who's doing
something that they love.
>>Joseph: We have majors in the school.
Those majors are the vocational areas
that the students can participate in.
We have a science department,
which is a combination
of traditional academic
sciences as well as research.
We have a technology department,
which is business technology,
computer applications
as well as graphic arts.
We have our architecture
and engineering academy
and then we have a performing
arts program which consists
of musical theater, dance,
audio technology and drama.
>>John: As a freshman they get to
pick four of our vocational courses
that they think they
might be interested in.
The next year as a sophomore,
they take two
of our vocational courses
for half a year.
And then when they really want to
commit, say, "Oh, this is what we want
to do," then they take a full
year, their junior and senior year.
>>Allyson: Every major needs
to have an advisory committee.
On that advisory committee,
you have parents,
you have students, you
have professionals.
We're very tied into industry, so
what we do is we go to our partners
and we say, "Tell us what
the students should know
by the time they get
out of high school."
And the idea is that what we're teaching
in school is relevant to industry.
>>John: in the twenty-first century,
communication, teamwork, research,
knowing where to go for
your information,
is paramount to having
a successful career.
>>Joseph: Our teachers stay on the
cutting edge of their particular area.
If they don't maintain
that dual citizenship,
they're going to be left
behind and we're not going
to offer our students
what they need to succeed.
>>Scott: I think as much as we can,
we try to share our own
experiences with them.
We have people coming in on a
regular basis, doing workshops
with our students, and some of that is
through our professional connections.
>>Arun: In my department,
there are four other PhDs.
They want to expand it
to the profession.
They wanted to have project
based learning.
Besides the regular classroom
teaching, you will see a lot
of students inside the lab,
white coats, eye goggles,
and working on their projects.
>>Angelica: We're trying to find out
heat of combustion of biofuels compared
to the heat of combustion of
diesel, because we're trying to see
which one's a better,
viable source of energy.
Right now, we're trying to
see how much heat it produces.
>>Arun: I give them only the
framework, so we are trying
to do it in a step process.
That's how science is done.
They are trying to solve a problem
and by doing that, they are learning.
>>Allyson: One thing we do here, which
I think is a little different is,
we have what are called unscheduled
periods, even for freshmen.
We want them to learn at fourteen
years old, how to manage their time.
>>Max: As a freshman, you have to do a
lot of work, but as you get used to it,
it becomes much more manageable and
you find that your work ethic improves.
>>Arun: Freedom is the
best thing for students.
If you give them this freedom to do
what they like or what they want to do,
and then guide them through that, then
you have quite successful students.
>>Allyson: We try and create a college
environment from the very beginning.
That's why we have unscheduled periods.
That's why we have remediation
programs after school,
a lot of social and emotional support.
I think the kids are happy and
I think that's why they do well.